we talk daily yeah all my review was
those guys are my brothers
and so we act like immature brothers all
the time Lance Bass exclusively taking
et down memory lane at his Los Angeles
home this week and responding to Justin
Timberlake's recent reveal about why he
took a step back from NSYNC he said I
felt like I cared more about the music
than some of the other people in the
group yeah that's true
I mean I don't think it's true I mean
obviously we cared about the music but I
understand where he's coming from for
sure because you know at the height of
NSYNC it was crazy I mean you're getting
pulled in so many directions and you do
feel like you're not in control anymore
and it felt like it was everything but
the music it was all about the spectacle
Lance is currently competing on the Fox
show my kitchen rules
but fatherhood is in his future just
like Justin's how do you think Justin
has grown up though as a dad and how is
he as a dad oh I think you know having a
kid completely changes you there's this
little person that that's all you that's
your life now so you put everything into
that little little person so yeah I
think you know and I've seen a change in
him I mean you're just so happy I've
never seen him happier and I'm so in
love with his family I can't wait for
you right to have a kid and then for
Silas and your channel he'll be all
right
I start a little band together the last
time that I talked to you was in
December and you said this spring you
and Michael we're going to start a
surrogacy process that's right what is
the status hopefully we you know get
pregnant this year fingers crossed
are you guys going to turn a room into a
nursery you better believe it it's gonna
be our closet stop I know
do you know Patrick baby uh no it's our
we turn one of our bedrooms into a big
walk-in closet so now our walk-in
closets gonna be the baby room well
actually it'll be a walk-in closet slash
baby room for the first couple years
until they realize
[Music]
you